and today I want to talk to you about
how you too can social engineer your
child through minecraft so first of this
is not a presentation for any kind of
parents there are some parents that are
not going to be interested in this for
instance if you want your child to be
happy and you're fine with that or if
you're fine with your child becoming an
artist or operating a B&B in Maine this
is not a presentation for you I'm
looking for Tiger mothers and Tiger
fathers for this presentation so this is
a child in question she's nine you can
see her now involved in some an
educational non-productive activity and
that is not going to I'm not going to
allow this to continue but thankfully
she loves Minecraft and that's great so
this is minecraft this is how it starts
you are dropped into a world with
nothing except your hand that's your
hand on the side there and you find a
tree and you chop it up you make planks
of woods and sticks with that you make
pickaxes you mind for rocks you build
houses sometimes you fight zombies but
mostly you build houses and bigger and
bigger houses so it's not it's a not
surprising that when I asked my daughter
what she thinks she's learning from
Minecraft she says hmm what is important
but of course there's much more to learn
from this this and this I forgot what
it's called but this is this game that
doesn't really have a goal but there
there's real knowledge to be gained from
Minecraft and for instance there's
something called redstone in Minecraft
that stands for electricity you can
actually build circuits it's also
obviously it fosters creativity so for
instance if you want to decorate your
house with a pit of severed heads like
my daughter did you can it's possible
minecraft also fosters flexibility so
this is a study done in Sweden about how
kids to play with Minecraft are very add
to scratch their plans when they
discover new resources or new tricks in
the world so for instance these kids
wanted to build a village but that they
change their plans when they discover
that they could carry water in buckets
and they instead they did water slides
but creativity and flexibility are low
hanging fruits educationally these are
the character traits that I want my
daughter to have these are the keep
school say this leads to success so does
minecraft help me with this so for
instance there's a problem of the
treehouse so my daughter builds giant
houses on top of tiny little trees and
she knows in our physics to know it's
not possible in real life so what's the
point so I called Katie salen and I
asked her that and she said yeah it it
does seem that building in possible
architecture would be a waste of time
but what really happens is that when the
kid then goes out in the streets finds a
tree will look at the tree and start
asking questions like well could I put a
house on that tree why not what would I
need to change to actually make it
happen and that puts the kid into a
mindset of problem solving and that's
really valuable and okay but there was
another there's another thing that I
wanted to teach my kid through minecraft
and it's to be brave and it says on the
website brave players but my daughter
when she plays in Minecraft
she's very risk-averse she avoids any
kind of race she doesn't fight the
zombies right so I asked Katie because I
had her on the phone and she said well
bravery really is great and perseverance
and you can cultivate that by setting
yourself challenges and achieving them
and then sharing the results on the
platform like DIY to get peer feedback
or parents feedback and that's really
important because that's your reward and
the kid will be more amenable to taking
risks if there's a
and that's my favorite part of minecraft
is that we talk a lot about what's going
on in side her minecraft word world and
we research ways to do things together
on YouTube and we bond over it so these
are the things that minecraft can teach
and it's not really that much different
from my original list and it's not so
bad for a simple video game and so now
the only thing that I have to worry
about is how to handle the pit of
severed heads thank you
[Applause]